[Musique]
on y est voilà le casino parfait c'est
là qu'on trouvera les pingouins
[Musique]
vous vous bagarez comme une troupe de
majorette enfer et courbouillon ses
oreillers sont bourrés de bébé
oiseau je descends en rappel je chope
les pingouins et on fit oh oh c'est moi
qui descends c'est moi qui les chop
sûment pas je descends et
je bouclez-moi l'immeuble et appelez la
brigade animalière
les
poulets capitaine du boire qu'est-ce que
je suis content de vous
voirouille comment lesvezv lachapper
lesaars faut vraiment qu'on bouge les
voil GIR je crois qu'on est
suiviad je suis là
défendu
comment va-ton arriver à traverser
l'urope sans attirer l'attention
regardez pour an de C seul pas faire
confi
au lui pas
lu çaent
lour n'oublie pas on la joue discret jus
que la pressionombe on est
invisible
c'est pas moi ah
[Musique]
ouis